would you try this
no i wouldn't
i would not i don't have that skill oh
my god the poor puppy
i'm dead i'm not gonna lie i probably
would drive okay let's watch it one more
time because i want to see the puppy
okay okay yeah yeah one more time over
time
so he's going and then
and then he
i mean i feel like he's not a good
bowler because he just can't go in the
middle a bowler yeah like cause you know
when you're the bowling ball like usual
oh oh i don't understand how the other
guy is running and why the dog he was
trying to help the guy the dog was
trying to help them and the guy was
trying the dog was trying to help like
are you good and then the guy was like
oh you're getting then it just there
were like three fails within one failed
video i loved it yeah it was
back-to-back yeah back to back to back
again i love this one just letting you
know okay i'm excited
okay
i'm going to give my dog an egg and
theoretically she pick excuse me miss
wait i believe she will understand that
she is taking care of it
[Music]
[Laughter]
theoretically she will understand that
she is supposed to take care of it
she has so many vines of well i said
vines wow
bring that vine a lot of her tick tocks
show her dog but she is like an illus
she's studying illustration so she gonna
illustrate that i think she should
that's like olivia for watching
[Music]
okay
i thought her pants came off too
i was like wow she's like bare
she looks like she's right it came out
yeah okay okay okay
wait is it we i'm i'm way played again i
think her tooth like completely chipped
off because it hit her knee
oh i just thought she had bad teeth
[Music]
i don't think so
because the captions couldn't help
myself good old tooth in the knee oh my
god she sent it hard so i think there's
a boat and it's pulling a tube but it
goes off like a ramp
that's pretty epic it is pretty that's
something that i would try this is the
second reaction video that i've done
where someone's convinced to do the
thing that i'm showing
i mean it's kind of a good idea yeah i
don't think it's that good of an idea
and the next trick is called the
hospital flip
why is he called a hospital
oh my gosh wait a minute can we play
that again yes
she's swinging
she's swinging
she almost
did you see that she almost hit her face
with the other person's face okay so
these people are pros she her name is
kate and she
is part of the cirque du soleil so she
is putting her life at risk every day
luckily enough they do have net but
okay i didn't see the name at first look
at that he starts off determined
determined faced determined faced not
abort mission this is bullsh she's
implemented
have you ever ridden a horse before uh
when i was like very little i rode a
horse
once i think i did i don't like it it
scares me horse riding is terrible and
this is only
confirming she falls truly on her back
yeah she falls on her back and like rag
dolls around the pole yeah and then she
stands up and she's fine and she kept
writing
ah
that just girls my god we make fun of
them but they they know a lot this is
scary to me because i i don't understand
how the body can like react like that
and then like just get up and be fine i
feel like you're just in shock maybe
yeah it's like the adrenaline's going
through your body and then she gets up
and chases the horse exactly worst date
has ever gone does pranks
[ __ ]
what was that mom it's easy easy pull
the fridge
wait did he yeah
like fully waxed his mom in the face
with like a broke like it breaks glass
yeah okay so she hit him first like fake
hits him
wait how come it didn't break on him
because he doesn't really hit him with
it he actually hits her because he's
just like doing it with it because like
it's like they like do like pranks on
each other and like stage it oh
so like acting either way his mom
definitely got slapped in the face with
a glass bottle
and it broke
[Music]
she's like yeah breaking your mom's face
the glass bottle hilarious thank you
guys for watching if there's anything
else you think we should watch do let us
know in the comments see you next time
yeah bye
[Music]